- Bem-vindo de volta a Entendendo Informação
e Computação Quântica.
Meu nome é John Watrous, e sou o diretor técnico
de Educação da IBM Quantum.
Esta é a segunda aula da série. Se você ainda não
assistiu à primeira aula, não deixe de conferir.
Vamos construir diretamente sobre o que discutimos
na primeira aula, então é importante ter uma
compreensão daquele material antes de entrar nesta aula.
Além disso, saiba que a série
inclui conteúdo de livro didático além dos vídeos, e você pode encontrar um link
para o conteúdo do livro didático
na descrição do vídeo. Esta é a aula dois da
unidade um da série.
A unidade um cobre os fundamentos
da informação quântica.
Na aula anterior, falamos sobre informação quântica no contexto de sistemas únicos, ou seja, temos um
sistema que armazena informação
e estamos descrevendo como
ele funciona de forma isolada.
Dedicamos um bom tempo à
informação clássica, principalmente para estabelecer um ponto de referência e destacar as
semelhanças matemáticas
entre a informação quântica e a clássica.
Também vimos como estados quânticos podem ser representados por vetores, especificamente vetores com
entradas de números complexos e norma euclidiana igual a um,
e discutimos medições na
base padrão e operações unitárias.
Nesta aula, vamos ampliar nossa
visão para múltiplos sistemas, cada um capaz de
armazenar informação quântica.
Isso não é simplesmente uma questão de dizer que cada sistema individual
funciona como discutimos da última vez, há um sentido em que o todo
é maior do que a soma das partes, e isso também vale para
a informação clássica quando há probabilidades envolvidas.
Múltiplos sistemas podem
interagir entre si e podem estar correlacionados
entre si, por exemplo, e no contexto quântico, isso inclui a possibilidade
de que os sistemas estejam entrelaçados, que é um termo que você
talvez já tenha ouvido antes.
O entrelaçamento é um fenômeno muito
importante na informação quântica e teremos muito mais a dizer sobre ele à medida que a série continua.
Existe um princípio simples, porém, que nos oferece bastante tração para pensar e
entender a informação quântica para múltiplos sistemas,
e é que podemos sempre
pegar dois ou mais sistemas e juntá-los ou simplesmente pensar sobre eles juntos
de forma conceitual
e tratá-los como se formassem
um único sistema composto.
E quando pensamos sobre um
sistema composto assim, como se fosse um único sistema, reconhecemos que ele deve ser descrito de uma forma consistente
com tudo que aprendemos
na aula anterior sobre sistemas únicos.
Veremos como isso funciona
e como a descrição da informação quântica
para múltiplos sistemas emerge de forma bastante natural a partir de como funciona para sistemas únicos
com base neste princípio. Aqui está uma visão geral da aula e ela é idêntica à visão geral da aula anterior,
mas desta vez nosso foco
será em múltiplos sistemas em vez de sistemas únicos.
Assim como fizemos na aula anterior e pelas mesmas razões, vamos começar com
a informação clássica.
Mais uma vez, veremos
semelhanças muito próximas entre a forma como a informação quântica
e a clássica funcionam em nível matemático.
Normalmente não vamos focar tanto
na informação clássica nem começar cada aula da série com informação clássica assim.
As aulas subsequentes tenderão a ser focadas muito mais exclusivamente em informação e computação quântica.
Mas aqui no início
essa é uma abordagem sensata e remete à ideia de que pensar sobre informação clássica
pode servir como uma fonte valiosa de orientação para entender a informação quântica.
Também vamos discutir
o importante conceito de produto tensorial nesta
parte da aula.
Produtos tensoriais são extremamente importantes na informação quântica, mas também aparecem no
contexto clássico.
Depois vamos para a informação quântica e, assim como na aula anterior, discutiremos estados quânticos,
medições na base padrão,
e operações unitárias desta
vez para múltiplos sistemas.
Vamos começar falando
sobre estados clássicos de múltiplos sistemas.
Lembrando da aula anterior
que um estado clássico de um sistema é uma
configuração desse sistema que pode ser reconhecida e
descrita sem ambiguidade
sem qualquer incerteza ou erro. E em termos matemáticos, quando nos referimos a um conjunto de estados clássicos,
simplesmente queremos dizer um conjunto finito e não vazio.
Vamos começar nossa discussão
sobre múltiplos sistemas supondo que temos
apenas dois sistemas X e Y.
X tem algum conjunto de estados clássicos que chamaremos de sigma, assim
como na aula anterior, e Y tem algum conjunto de estados clássicos
que chamaremos de gamma. Os conjuntos sigma e gamma
podem ser o mesmo conjunto ou podem ser diferentes,
mas estamos dando nomes diferentes a eles, não só porque
podem ser conjuntos diferentes, mas também porque vai nos
ajudar a manter as coisas claras se dermos nomes diferentes a eles.
Vamos descobrir que é
bastante fácil generalizar toda essa discussão de dois sistemas para qualquer número de sistemas, mas
começando com dois sistemas,
podemos focar nas ideias fundamentais sem nos perder em detalhes.
Agora, imagine que
colocamos X e Y lado a lado com X à esquerda e Y à direita, e tratamos esses dois sistemas juntos
como se formassem um único sistema composto.
Para dar um nome a esse novo sistema, podemos escrevê-lo como um
par ordenado assim, ou podemos simplesmente justapos
as duas letras assim.
Ambas as formas são comuns e podemos
escolher qualquer uma ou a que for mais conveniente.
De qualquer forma, vamos lê-lo como XY.
Uma pergunta bem natural
a fazer neste ponto é quais são os estados clássicos desse novo sistema composto XY?
E a resposta a essa pergunta é que o conjunto de estados clássicos de XY é o produto cartesiano dos
dois conjuntos de estados clássicos,
sigma e gamma, que você
pode ver definido aqui.
Em determinado momento, X tem algum estado clássico
que é um elemento de sigma, e Y tem algum estado clássico
que é um elemento de gamma,
e simplesmente estamos pensando
sobre esses dois estados juntos como se formassem um único estado, e é exatamente essa a noção
que o produto cartesiano captura. Temos dois elementos,
um de cada um dos nossos conjuntos, e queremos pensar sobre
esses dois elementos juntos
como se formassem um único
elemento de um único conjunto.
Para ficar claro, há uma suposição aqui que é que sabemos
qual dos nossos sistemas é X e qual é Y,
e não há confusão entre eles. Não é importante que X esteja fisicamente à
esquerda e Y à direita,
mas sim que os dois
sistemas sejam distinguíveis e que decidimos
ordená-los desta forma apenas para manter
claro qual é qual.
Aqui está um exemplo bem simples onde sigma é o alfabeto binário e gamma é o conjunto
contendo os quatro naipes de cartas.
Se X armazena um valor binário e Y armazena um dos quatro naipes de cartas, então há oito
possíveis estados clássicos
do par XY, que você
pode ver listados aqui.
Para mais de dois sistemas, isso se generaliza de forma direta.
Em particular, se X1 até Xn são sistemas com conjuntos de estados clássicos sigma um até sigma n, respectivamente.
Então se imaginarmos agrupar
os n sistemas juntos e tratá-los como um sistema, o conjunto de estados clássicos é
dado pelo produto cartesiano
dos n conjuntos de estados clássicos
sigma um até sigma n.
Como você pode ver aqui na tela. O produto cartesiano
pode ser definido assim para qualquer número de conjuntos.
Por exemplo, se temos três sistemas e todos compartilham o alfabeto binário como seu conjunto de estados clássicos, ou seja, temos três bits,
então há oito
possíveis estados clássicos dos três bits tratados
juntos como um único sistema e você pode vê-los listados aqui.
Cada sistema individualmente pode
estar no estado zero ou um, e percorremos todas as
possíveis combinações.
Uma n-upla de estados clássicos pode ser escrita alternativamente como uma string onde eliminamos os
parênteses e a vírgula como você vê aqui.
E isso é particularmente razoável quando pensamos sobre
estados clássicos como símbolos como no exemplo muito comum
do alfabeto binário
ao qual sempre voltamos. Às vezes é muito conveniente fazer isso e tende a tornar
nossas expressões mais simples
e menos poluídas. A noção de string é de fato formalizada
em termos matemáticos por meio de produtos cartesianos,
então isso é realmente apenas
uma notação alternativa e não algo conceitualmente diferente.
Como exemplo, digamos que temos
10 bits X1 até X10.
Isso significa que o conjunto de estados clássicos dos 10 bits juntos,
que você naturalmente pode pensar como um registrador de 10 bits
em um computador, por exemplo,
é o produto cartesiano décuplo
do alfabeto binário consigo mesmo.
E se escrevemos esses estados como strings, eles parecem como você vê
aqui, há 1.024 deles,
então é claro que não estão todos listados aqui. Esses três pontos aqui
devem indicar que há um padrão que você pode deduzir
e esperamos que entendas a ideia. Agora há uma convenção
que vamos seguir para ordenar os elementos
dos conjuntos de produto cartesiano,
e é importante
esclarecer isso para fins de representar tanto estados probabilísticos quanto estados quânticos como vetores.
A convenção é que
ordenamos os elementos dos conjuntos de produto cartesiano
lexicograficamente, o que basicamente significa ordenação de dicionário.
Para ser mais específico, começamos com a suposição de que cada um dos conjuntos individuais cujo produto cartesiano estamos tomando já tem sua própria ordenação
e pensamos sobre uma
dada n-upla ou string como se fosse uma palavra e as
ordenamos alfabeticamente.
Outra forma de dizer isso é que as posições dentro de
uma n-upla ou string diminuem em significância
da esquerda para a direita,
assim como quando escrevemos números usando os dígitos zero a nove.
Aqui está um exemplo que tem
o objetivo de esclarecer isso.
Se tomamos o produto cartesiano entre os conjuntos contendo
um, dois e três e o alfabeto binário, obtemos um conjunto contendo seis elementos
e aqui eles estão listados na
ordem que está sendo descrita.
Todos os elementos com um
na primeira posição vêm antes de todos os elementos com dois na primeira posição e estes vêm antes de todos os elementos
com três na primeira posição. E sempre que dois elementos
concordam na primeira posição, recorremos à ordenação
na segunda posição.
Então essa é a ordenação que
usamos para os produtos cartesianos.
Note que quando usamos essa convenção e escrevemos n-uplas como strings, observamos alguns padrões muito familiares.
Por exemplo, o produto cartesiano do
alfabeto binário consigo mesmo é ordenado como você vê aqui,
e você pode pensar nessas strings como sendo ordenadas numericamente se tratar essas strings
como codificações binárias de inteiros não negativos
e isso se generaliza
para qualquer comprimento de string. Passando para os estados probabilísticos, já sabemos da aula anterior
que um estado probabilístico associa uma probabilidade a cada estado clássico
de um determinado sistema.
Se temos um sistema composto onde pegamos dois ou mais sistemas e os tratamos coletivamente como se formassem um único
sistema como acabamos de discutir,
então um estado probabilístico
desse sistema composto deve atribuir probabilidades aos elementos do produto cartesiano
dos sistemas individuais,
conjuntos de estados clássicos. É porque esse é
o conjunto de estados clássicos do sistema composto.
Por exemplo, supondo
que X e Y são bits, temos este exemplo de um
estado probabilístico de XY.
A probabilidade de que ambos os
bits sejam zero é um meio e a probabilidade de que ambos os
bits sejam um é um meio, e portanto os dois bits nunca discordam.
É um estado probabilístico válido de XY, e podemos escrevê-lo alternativamente
como um vetor
como você vê aqui e aqui você pode ver que estamos
seguindo a convenção que descrevi há pouco para ordenar esses estados clássicos.
Este é um exemplo de
um estado probabilístico onde X e Y estão correlacionados, e este é o sentido em que o todo
é maior do que a soma das partes. Como sugeri antes, não é simplesmente que temos um estado probabilístico
de X e um estado probabilístico de Y e os juntamos, mas sim que primeiro juntamos
os sistemas
e depois pensamos sobre
estados probabilísticos do sistema composto.
Para ser mais preciso sobre
correlações entre sistemas, começamos definindo a
noção de independência, que é essencialmente a
ausência de correlação.
Aqui, aliás, o termo independência se refere
à independência estatística em oposição à independência linear
de vetores, por exemplo.
É uma noção fundamental em
probabilidade e estatística.
Se temos dois sistemas X e Y e temos algum estado probabilístico
de XY em mente, então dizemos que X e Y são independentes.
Se a fórmula que você
vê aqui é verdadeira para toda escolha de estados clássicos
a e b de X e Y.
Uma forma de interpretar essa
condição de independência é que ela diz que a probabilidade de X estar em qualquer estado clássico
e a probabilidade de Y estar em algum outro estado clássico não têm absolutamente nada
a ver uma com a outra.
Então, saber em que estado
um dos sistemas está não afeta as
probabilidades associadas aos estados do outro sistema.
Se você imaginar escolher aleatoriamente
algum estado clássico de X segundo algum procedimento e depois escolher aleatoriamente
algum estado clássico de Y
segundo algum outro procedimento que não está de nenhuma forma
conectado ao de X, como se uma pessoa jogar uma moeda
e outra pessoa em uma
sala diferente jogar um dado, então esta é a fórmula
que você usaria para obter as probabilidades
para diferentes combinações
de estados aparecerem. O ponto da definição é que independência é
quando a fórmula é válida.
Quando pensamos sobre estados probabilísticos em termos de vetores de probabilidade, há uma formulação simples
dessa condição
especificamente se temos um
estado probabilístico de XY, que podemos expressar como um
vetor na notação de Dirac
como você vê aqui. Então dizer que X e Y são independentes é equivalente à existência
de dois vetores de probabilidade,
ket Phi e ket Psi que aliás podemos
simplesmente ler como Phi e Psi por brevidade, representando
estados probabilísticos de X e Y separadamente que satisfazem essa igualdade
que você vê aqui.
Para todas as escolhas de a e b, é essencialmente uma
reformulação da definição em termos de vetores.
Por exemplo, aqui está um estado probabilístico
de um par de bits XY para o qual X e Y são independentes.
A condição que é
necessária para independência é verdadeira para os vetores
que você vê aqui.
Ou seja, a probabilidade
para cada possível configuração dos dois bits é dada pelo produto das probabilidades correspondentes
para os bits individuais.
Por exemplo, a probabilidade de ambos os
bits tomarem o valor zero é igual a um sexto, que é igual a um
quarto vezes dois terços,
e o mesmo vale para as
outras três possibilidades que podem ser verificadas uma de cada vez.
Para o estado probabilístico que vimos antes, por outro lado, onde
temos dois bits que sempre concordam e tomam os valores zero e
um com probabilidade um meio
não temos independência e é por isso que dizemos que
os bits estão correlacionados.
Correlação simplesmente significa
ausência de independência.
Uma forma simples de argumentar que os
dois bits não são independentes é supor que são e derivar uma contradição
especificamente se os dois
bits fossem independentes, teriam que existir
números q0, q1, r0 e r1
representando probabilidades
para os dois bits individuais de modo que essas equações
aqui fossem satisfeitas.
Essas são as probabilidades
que vêm do nosso vetor e essas são as
equações que devem ser verdadeiras pela condição de independência,
mas se olharmos para essa
segunda igualdade aqui, vemos que ela exige que
q0 vezes r1 seja igual a zero,
mas a única forma de que o
produto de dois números reais possa ser igual a zero é se pelo menos um desses
números em si seja igual a zero.
Isso é às vezes chamado de
a propriedade do produto zero dos números reais.
Outra forma de dizer é que o produto de dois números reais não nulos
é sempre não nulo.
Então essa igualdade aqui
implica que ou q0 é igual a zero ou r1 é igual a zero,
mas pelas primeira e última igualdades vemos que nenhuma das
duas alternativas pode ser verdadeira.
Se q0 é igual a zero, então esse produto deve ser igual a zero, mas não é igual a zero
e se r1 é igual a zero,
então esse produto deve ser igual a zero, mas isso também não é verdade.
Então temos uma contradição
e concluímos que X e Y não são independentes, portanto estão correlacionados.
A noção de independência
que acabamos de discutir e especificamente sua formulação em termos de vetores de probabilidade está intimamente relacionada
a uma operação que pode
ser realizada em vetores conhecida como produto tensorial.
Produtos tensoriais podem ser
definidos não só para vetores, mas também para matrizes
e de fato a noção de produto tensorial pode ser definida
para muitos outros tipos de
objetos matemáticos também.
Eles podem ser descritos
de uma forma bastante abstrata que é importante e
útil na matemática pura, mas também podemos definir
produtos tensoriais para vetores
de uma forma muito simples e concreta, e esse é o caminho que
seguiremos nesta aula.
Se temos dois vetores coluna Phi e Psi escritos nas formas que você vê aqui onde sigma e gamma são qualquer
escolha de conjuntos de estados clássicos
que quisermos ou índices se preferirmos, então o produto tensorial desses vetores é o vetor que você vê aqui.
Percorremos todos os elementos
do produto cartesiano dos dois conjuntos, sigma e gamma, e a entrada desse
vetor que corresponde
a cada par ab, que é
escrito como string aqui, é igual ao produto das
entradas correspondentes
desses dois vetores. Em outras palavras, a entrada ab de Phi tensorial Psi é o produto da entrada a
de Phi e da entrada b de Psi,
e esse é o significado do
que está escrito aqui.
Em essência, esta é a mesma operação que vimos há alguns momentos quando discutimos independência
e agora estamos apenas dando um nome a ela.
Aqui está exatamente o mesmo exemplo
que vimos há pouco escrito mais explicitamente em
termos do produto tensorial.
Novamente, temos que um sexto é igual a um quarto vezes um terço, um doze avos é igual a um quarto
vezes um terço e assim por diante.
Aqui, aliás, estão
algumas formas alternativas de escrever o produto
tensorial de dois vetores.
Quando usamos a notação de Dirac e escrevemos dois kets
lado a lado assim, significa o produto tensorial.
Então você pode pensar no produto tensorial como sendo a forma padrão de multiplicar dois vetores coluna juntos.
Não faria nenhum sentido
pensar em um produto de vetores coluna assim em termos de multiplicação de matrizes porque as dimensões não funcionam,
então realmente não há preocupação
com ambiguidade aqui.
Também podemos escrever o
produto tensorial assim dentro de um ket e significa
exatamente a mesma coisa.
É o produto tensorial
dos dois vetores.
O primeiro é muito comum e de fato é talvez mais comum escrever um produto tensorial assim sem o símbolo do produto tensorial
do que incluir o símbolo. O segundo é
definitivamente muito menos comum, mas às vezes é bastante útil principalmente
como forma de eliminar a necessidade
de parênteses adicionais em certas situações.
Também podemos expressar
produtos tensoriais explicitamente em termos de colunas reais de
números como você vê aqui,
se tomamos o produto tensorial desses dois vetores coluna aqui, então este é o vetor que obtemos
e você pode ver que as entradas aqui são produtos das entradas
provenientes desses dois vetores.
A ordenação das entradas
do produto tensorial é consistente com a
definição de há pouco, desde que sigamos a convenção
que descrevi anteriormente para ordenar os elementos
dos conjuntos de produto cartesiano.
Seguir essa convenção é equivalente a pensar
sobre os índices do primeiro vetor como
tendo maior significância do que os índices do segundo vetor,
então você pode ver que à medida que
percorremos as entradas do produto tensorial, temos todos os produtos envolvendo a primeira entrada do
primeiro vetor à esquerda,
que é alfa um. Depois todos os produtos
envolvendo a segunda entrada do vetor à esquerda,
que é alfa dois e assim por diante.
Aqui está um exemplo onde
o vetor à esquerda tem três entradas e o vetor à
direita tem quatro entradas para que possamos ver mais
claramente o que está acontecendo.
Temos três entradas no primeiro vetor, então começamos escrevendo três cópias do segundo vetor e depois multiplicamos cada uma dessas cópias
pela entrada correspondente
no primeiro vetor assim.
Trazemos os alfas para dentro assim, e aqui estamos apenas
multiplicando vetores por escalares
e finalmente removemos os
parênteses das cópias e formamos um único vetor coluna
como você vê aqui.
Como um aparte importante, note que temos as seguintes fórmulas para o produto tensorial de
vetores da base padrão.
Se tomamos o produto
tensorial de ket a e ket b, que podemos escrever com
o símbolo de produto tensorial ou sem, como você vê aqui,
então o resultado é simplesmente ket ab.
Se quisermos escrever ab como um par ordenado em vez de uma string, podemos fazer isso e obtemos
esta expressão aqui,
mas é muito mais comum
escrever isso aqui onde omitimos o parêntese
mas deixamos a vírgula.
Há um sentido em que
este com o parêntese talvez seja mais correto, mas é uma convenção bastante padrão em matemática
que parênteses são removidos quando não são necessários ou úteis.
Você pode pensar neles como sendo implícitos neste aqui e é apenas menos poluído
e mais agradável de ver.
O produto tensorial tem
uma propriedade importante que é ser bilinear e o que isso significa é que é linear
em cada um dos dois argumentos, desde que o outro esteja fixo.
Com um pouco mais de detalhe, é
linear no primeiro argumento, o que é expresso por essas duas equações que você vê aqui,
a primeira diz que
se somamos dois vetores, Phi1 e Phi2 e depois tomamos
o produto tensorial com Psi, obtemos o mesmo resultado se
tivéssemos tomado o produto tensorial
com Psi primeiro e depois somado.
A segunda diz que se
multiplicamos algum vetor Phi por algum escalar alfa e depois tomamos o
produto tensorial com Psi,
o resultado é o mesmo que se tivéssemos primeiro tomado o produto tensorial de Phi e Psi e depois multiplicado o resultado por alfa.
E também temos linearidade
no segundo argumento que é o mesmo exceto que os papéis dos dois argumentos são trocados.
Essa propriedade de bilinearidade
é bem simples de verificar a partir da definição, mas é bom escrever assim porque frequentemente faremos
uso dessas fórmulas.
Note aliás que escalares flutuam livremente através de produtos tensoriais no sentido expresso por essas
igualdades que você vê aqui.
Ou seja, não há diferença
entre multiplicar o primeiro argumento por um
escalar alfa, neste caso multiplicar o segundo
argumento por esse escalar
ou multiplicar o todo
por esse escalar.
Essas igualdades decorrem de
essas duas equações aqui e porque não há
diferença entre esses vetores, podemos simplesmente escrever a
expressão como você vê aqui
sem parênteses porque
não há necessidade deles.
Eles não estão adicionando clareza
nem removendo ambiguidade, então simplesmente os removemos e
obtemos uma expressão mais limpa.
Tudo isso se generaliza
para três ou mais sistemas.
Podemos definir o produto tensorial
de três ou mais vetores generalizando a fórmula
para o produto tensorial de dois vetores de forma natural,
que você pode ver expresso aqui. Cada entrada do produto tensorial é dada pelo produto das
entradas correspondentes
dos vetores cujo produto tensorial estamos
tomando.
Uma forma equivalente de
definir o produto tensorial de três ou mais vetores
é fazê-lo recursivamente, retornando à definição
do produto tensorial entre dois vetores. Então se n é pelo menos três, podemos pensar sobre o
produto tensorial de n vetores
Phi1 até Phi n como sendo o produto tensorial entre qualquer vetor que obtemos ao
tomar o produto tensorial dos primeiros n menos um deles com o último vetor,
e se você quiser saber
qual é o produto tensorial dos primeiros n menos um vetores, você aplica a fórmula
novamente caso n menos um
seja pelo menos três ou usa a definição
anterior se n menos um é igual a dois.
As duas formas de pensar
sobre produtos tensoriais de três ou mais vetores são equivalentes.
Desta vez, quando temos
três ou mais vetores cujo produto tensorial estamos tomando, não usamos o termo bilinear,
usamos em vez disso o termo multilinear,
mas a ideia é a mesma.
O produto tensorial é linear
em cada uma das posições, desde que os vetores em
todas as outras posições
estejam fixos. Passando para medições
de múltiplos sistemas em estados probabilísticos,
imediatamente obtemos uma especificação de como as medições
funcionam para múltiplos sistemas simplesmente pensando sobre eles
coletivamente como sistemas únicos
desde que todos os
sistemas sejam medidos.
Como um exemplo simples, vamos supor que temos dois
bits X e Y e coletivamente eles estão neste estado probabilístico
aqui,
que vimos antes. Naturalmente, se medirmos
ambos esses bits, obteremos o resultado 00
significando zero para a primeira medição e zero para a segunda medição com probabilidade um meio e obteremos o resultado 1,1
com probabilidade um meio também. Isso é bastante direto.
Em essência, medir todos os sistemas é equivalente a medir
o sistema composto inteiro.
Se não medirmos todos
os sistemas, porém, mas medirmos apenas
alguns dos sistemas, então a situação não é
tão imediatamente clara
restringindo nossa atenção mais uma vez ao caso de apenas dois
sistemas para ver a essência do que está acontecendo da forma mais
simples possível.
Podemos fazer a seguinte pergunta, suponha que temos dois sistemas, X e Y que estão juntos como um par
em algum estado probabilístico particular.
O que acontece se medirmos
apenas X e não fizermos nada a Y?
Bom, podemos responder a essa pergunta usando um pouco de teoria básica de probabilidade.
Primeiro, sabemos que a probabilidade de que a medição
forneça um resultado particular deve ser dada por esta fórmula
que você vê aqui.
Podemos pensar sobre as probabilidades para cada um dos estados clássicos
do par XY como se tivéssemos medido ambos e somamos todas as probabilidades
que são consistentes com X estando em qualquer estado clássico
a em que estamos interessados.
É por isso que a soma aqui é apenas sobre os estados clássicos b de Y.
Uma forma de pensar sobre essa
fórmula é que a probabilidade de ver um estado clássico particular
de X se o medirmos
deve ser consistente com a probabilidade de ver esse estado se
também tivéssemos medido Y, mesmo que não tenhamos,
isso é muito natural e intuitivo. A probabilidade de que uma medição de X produza um resultado particular pode possivelmente depender de se Y
também foi medido
independentemente do resultado.
Então isso nos diz quais
são as probabilidades para os diferentes possíveis
resultados da medição, mas o que acontece com Y ou nosso
conhecimento de Y como resultado?
A resposta é que ainda
pode existir alguma incerteza sobre o estado de Y como
resultado de termos medido X
e visto um resultado particular. E essa incerteza é representada por esta fórmula aqui para a probabilidade condicional
de que Y está em algum estado clássico particular b, dado que X está em algum estado clássico,
qualquer estado clássico a,
que acontecemos de ter medido.
Para ser preciso, a probabilidade de que Y está
em algum estado clássico b, dado que X está no estado clássico a,
é igual à probabilidade
de que X está em a e Y está em b dividida pela probabilidade de que X
está no estado clássico a.
Então se medirmos X, vamos ver
diferentes estados clássicos com probabilidades determinadas
por esta fórmula aqui
e dependendo de qual resultado obtemos, ainda pode haver alguma incerteza sobre o estado clássico de Y e
essa incerteza é refletida
por esta fórmula aqui.
Na verdade, há uma forma muito fácil
de reformular tudo isso e realizar cálculos
para casos específicos usando a notação de Dirac
e funciona assim.
Começamos escrevendo o
estado probabilístico de XY como um vetor assim, e
isso é completamente geral.
As entradas são denotadas por Pab e esses podem ser quaisquer números, desde que o vetor inteiro
seja um vetor de probabilidade.
Podemos expressar ket ab como um
produto tensorial como você vê aqui e depois podemos usar a
bilinearidade do produto tensorial
e especificamente o fato de ser linear no segundo argumento para expressar este vetor
como você vê aqui.
O que estamos fazendo é efetivamente isolar os vetores da base padrão
no lado esquerdo e colocar o que precisarmos
no lado direito
para permitir isso porque isso vai revelar o que acontece quando
medimos o primeiro sistema X.
Especificamente, a probabilidade
de obter um resultado particular a é a soma sobre todas as probabilidades que aparecem no
parêntese ao lado do ket a.
E condicionado a obter
um resultado particular a, o vetor de probabilidade que descreve qualquer incerteza que resta sobre Y
é o vetor que estava
nos parênteses ao lado de a.
Exceto que temos que normalizá-lo para que seja um vetor de probabilidade e isso é dizer que
temos que dividir esse vetor
pela soma das entradas nesse vetor para formar um vetor de probabilidade.
Aqui, aliás, a soma é tomada sobre todo
c em gamma em vez de b apenas para usar um nome de variável diferente para que não haja confusão
sobre o escopo das
variáveis por assim dizer.
As somas no numerador
e no denominador devem ser consideradas como coisas separadas e podemos evitar qualquer chance
de confusão sobre isso
usando variáveis diferentes
para as duas somas.
Aqui está um exemplo rápido para
ilustrar como tudo isso funciona.
Suponha que XY é um par de bits neste estado probabilístico aqui, para entender o que acontece
quando medimos o primeiro bit
e não fazemos nada ao segundo, escrevemos o vetor como você vê aqui onde ket zero e ket
um na primeira posição
são isolados exatamente como
descrevemos há poucos momentos.
A primeira possibilidade é
que o resultado da medição seja zero e a probabilidade
de isso acontecer é a soma das probabilidades
dentro dos parênteses
que estão tensoradas ao ket zero. Então obtemos um doze avos mais um quarto, que é um terço e
condicionado ao resultado zero.
O estado probabilístico de Y
torna-se esse vetor normalizado ou equivalentemente dividido pela probabilidade
que acabamos de calcular, e então o que obtemos é
esse vetor aqui.
A segunda possibilidade é que o resultado da medição seja um e o cálculo é
feito de forma similar usando o segundo termo na expressão
em vez do primeiro termo. E se quiser verificar os detalhes, pode como sempre pausar o vídeo para se dar um momento de fazer isso.
Você pode realizar os mesmos
tipos de cálculos para descobrir o que acontece quando
Y é medido em vez de X.
É o mesmo método, dada a simetria entre os dois sistemas.
Desta vez escrevemos o
vetor de probabilidade assim, isolando os vetores da base padrão à direita como você vê aqui,
mas de resto funciona
exatamente da mesma forma.
Você também pode usar esse método
para mais de dois sistemas.
Pode ficar um pouco
complicado para escrever todas as expressões necessárias, mas conceitualmente é
exatamente a mesma ideia.
Por fim, para a parte da aula
sobre informação clássica, vamos dar uma olhada nas operações
em estados probabilísticos
de múltiplos sistemas. Seguindo o mesmo raciocínio que já vimos algumas vezes.
Concluímos que operações probabilísticas em múltiplos sistemas são iguais
às operações probabilísticas em sistemas únicos, representadas
por matrizes estocásticas.
Mas desta vez essas matrizes
têm linhas e colunas que correspondem ao produto cartesiano dos conjuntos de estados clássicos dos sistemas individuais.
Ou seja, simplesmente
tratamos um sistema composto como se fosse um único sistema e recorremos à descrição de como operações probabilísticas funcionam
para sistemas únicos da
aula anterior.
Aqui está um exemplo de uma operação chamada operação NOT controlado
em dois bits X e Y.
Esta é na verdade uma operação determinística e a forma como funciona é
que se X é igual a um, então uma operação NOT é realizada em Y
e caso contrário, se X é igual
a zero, então nada acontece.
O bit X é às vezes
chamado de bit de controle porque determina se
a operação NOT é aplicada a Y
e Y é chamado de bit alvo porque é o bit que é atuado pela operação NOT.
Você também pode imaginar
trocar os papéis de X e Y de forma que Y se torne o bit de controle
e X se torne o alvo, mas essa é uma operação diferente
da que é descrita aqui porque a operação não é
simétrica entre X e Y.
Ambas são chamadas de
operações NOT controlado, e apenas precisamos especificar
qual dos bits é o bit de controle e
qual é o bit alvo.
Esta operação tem a ação
que você vê aqui sobre estados da base padrão e você pode verificar essa
ação em relação à definição
da operação. E aqui está a representação matricial da operação.
Quando pensamos sobre essa operação, temos em mente que há
esses dois bits separados e eles desempenham os papéis que acabei de descrever com
X sendo o bit de controle
e Y sendo o bit alvo, mas realmente não há nada
sobre essa ação aqui ou essa representação matricial
que exija que
pensemos nesses dois bits como sendo bits separados.
Alternativamente, podemos apenas
pensar nessa operação como sendo uma operação determinística em um sistema com quatro estados clássicos
que decidimos nomear
0,0, 0,1, 1,0 e 1,1.
Aqui está outro exemplo de
uma operação probabilística em dois bits, que não é uma operação determinística desta vez.
A operação define Y como sendo igual a X com probabilidade um meio e caso contrário vai pelo outro caminho e define X como sendo igual a Y.
Essa operação não tem um nome especial, é apenas um exemplo.
E aqui está a representação matricial dessa operação.
Você pode ver que ela pode ser expressa como uma média de duas matrizes, uma que representa a operação determinística
onde Y é definido como seja qual for
o valor armazenado em X e a outra que define
X como sendo igual a Y.
Então aqui vemos que podemos tomar médias de matrizes estocásticas para obter novas, assim como tínhamos na aula anterior.
Agora, vamos considerar
a seguinte pergunta. Suponha que temos duas
operações probabilísticas, cada uma em seu próprio sistema
descritas como de costume por matrizes estocásticas
e para ser preciso, suponha que M é
uma operação probabilística
em um sistema X e N é uma
operação probabilística em um sistema Y.
A questão é: se
realizarmos simultaneamente M em X e N em Y, como descrevemos
o efeito que isso tem
no sistema composto XY?
Pensando sobre isso
intuitivamente por um momento, se realizarmos simultaneamente as duas operações em seus respectivos sistemas,
então de fato estamos
realizando uma operação no sistema composto, então ela deve ser descrita
por alguma matriz estocástica.
A resposta curta para essa
questão é que a matriz é obtida tomando um produto tensorial, não entre vetores como
falamos antes,
mas entre matrizes neste
caso, as matrizes M e N.
Então vamos dedicar alguns momentos
para discutir produtos tensoriais de matrizes e depois voltaremos
a essa questão.
Aqui está a definição
do produto tensorial entre matrizes e
é muito análogo ao produto tensorial entre vetores.
Se supomos que as duas
matrizes com as quais estamos trabalhando são escritas nas formas que você vê aqui de modo que as entradas de M são
denotadas alfa ab com a e b
variando sobre algum conjunto de estados clássicos sigma e as entradas de N são
denotadas por beta cd com c e d
variando sobre algum conjunto de estados clássicos gamma.
Então o produto de M e N é a matriz que você vê aqui.
O que temos é semelhante
ao produto tensorial entre vetores.
as linhas e colunas de M tensorial N correspondem a pares de estados clássicos que são escritos como strings aqui,
e as entradas são produtos das entradas correspondentes de M e N.
Aqui está outra forma de escrever em termos das entradas individuais
dessas matrizes.
A entrada ac bd de M tensorial N é o produto da entrada ab
de M e da entrada cd de N.
Há outra forma de
descrever M tensorial N, que é que é a
única matriz que transforma qualquer vetor da forma Phi tensorial Psi
no produto tensorial de M aplicado a Phi com N aplicado a Psi, e isso deve ser verdade para toda escolha
desses vetores Phi e Psi.
Uma forma de pensar sobre
isso é que o produto tensorial de matrizes se encaixa perfeitamente com o produto tensorial entre vetores.
Esta é uma equação que você
naturalmente esperaria ser verdadeira e de fato é.
Em termos de matrizes que
são escritas explicitamente, podemos definir o produto
tensorial como você vê aqui.
Há muitos pontos nessa equação e eles devem
ilustrar o padrão, que é o mesmo padrão
que tínhamos para vetores, exceto que agora temos linhas e colunas
em oposição a apenas vetores coluna.
Caso não esteja claro, o
seguinte exemplo pode ajudar.
Aqui estamos falando sobre
o produto tensorial de duas matrizes dois por dois.
Primeiro escrevemos quatro
cópias da segunda matriz, uma para cada entrada da primeira matriz.
Multiplicamos cada uma dessas
cópias da segunda matriz pela entrada correspondente
da primeira matriz,
e depois juntamos tudo em
uma única matriz quatro por quatro como você vê aqui.
Também podemos definir o
produto tensorial de três ou mais matrizes de forma análoga e talvez a forma mais fácil
de expressar isso
é como você vê aqui
onde temos uma fórmula para cada entrada do produto tensorial, que é simplesmente o produto
das entradas correspondentes.
Você também pode definir o produto tensorial de três ou mais matrizes recursivamente em termos do produto
tensorial de apenas duas matrizes, assim como tínhamos para vetores.
E uma nota final é
que o produto tensorial de matrizes é multiplicativo, o que significa que um
produto de produtos tensoriais
é igual ao produto tensorial
dos produtos.
Você pode pensar sobre
isso como uma generalização da fórmula de há poucos momentos para a ação do produto tensorial
de matrizes
sobre o produto tensorial de vetores. E novamente, isso é algo que
certamente esperaríamos ser verdade e podemos nos alegrar que seja
e faremos uso desse
fato quando necessário.
E agora podemos voltar à
questão de antes que pergunta como descrevemos
o efeito de realizar uma operação M em um sistema X
e uma operação N no sistema Y juntas como uma operação
no sistema composto XY.
E a resposta a essa
questão é que a ação é descrita pelo
produto tensorial de M e N.
Produtos tensoriais representam independência, desta vez entre operações, em oposição ao que vimos
antes para vetores de probabilidade.
Aqui está um exemplo rápido. Suponha que realizamos
a operação probabilística descrita por esta matriz em um bit X.
Esta é de fato uma operação
que vimos na aula um e simultaneamente realizamos
uma operação NOT em um bit Y.
A operação combinada no par XY é portanto representada pelo produto tensorial das matrizes correspondentes a essas duas operações.
Aqui está a de X e
aqui está a operação NOT em Y e obtemos esta matriz
que você vê aqui.
E você pode ver que de fato
essa é uma matriz estocástica e esse sempre será o caso.
O produto tensorial de quaisquer
duas matrizes estocásticas ou de qualquer número de matrizes
estocásticas será sempre estocástico.
É uma situação muito comum
que encontramos, em que uma operação é
realizada em um sistema e nada é feito a outro sistema.
Nessa situação, seguimos exatamente a mesma prescrição com o entendimento de que não fazer nada é representado pela matriz identidade.
Por exemplo, se temos dois bits X e
Y e resetamos o bit X para o estado zero, que é a mesma coisa
que realizar a função constante
zero em X e não fazemos nada a Y, então a operação resultante no par XY
é representada por esse
produto tensorial aqui.
Tudo isso se generaliza
para qualquer número de sistemas e veremos alguns exemplos adicionais quando passarmos para o contexto quântico, que funciona exatamente da mesma forma
exceto que temos matrizes unitárias em vez de matrizes estocásticas, e isso é suficiente sobre
informação clássica por enquanto.
Agora voltaremos nossa atenção
para a informação quântica e como ela funciona para múltiplos sistemas.
O padrão é o mesmo de
como foi para a informação clássica.
Podemos tratar múltiplos sistemas quânticos como sistemas compostos únicos e aplicar o que sabemos
da aula anterior.
Novamente, produtos tensoriais
desempenharão um papel fundamental e no geral obtemos uma descrição de como a informação quântica
funciona para múltiplos sistemas.
Que é muito análoga
e matematicamente similar ao que acabamos de ver para
a informação clássica.
Começaremos com os estados quânticos.
Estados quânticos de múltiplos sistemas são representados por vetores coluna com entradas de números complexos
e norma euclidiana igual a um
assim como os estados quânticos
de sistemas únicos.
Desta vez os índices dos
vetores de estado quântico correspondem ao produto cartesiano dos conjuntos de estados clássicos
dos sistemas individuais
porque novamente, esse é
o conjunto de estados clássicos do sistema composto.
Por exemplo, se X e Y são qubits, então o conjunto de estados clássicos
do par XY junto é o produto cartesiano do
alfabeto binário consigo mesmo,
que podemos pensar como
o conjunto de todas as strings binárias de comprimento dois.
Então esses vetores que você vê aqui são todos exemplos de vetores de
estado quântico de XY.
Se quisermos, podemos escrever
esses vetores assim onde temos um ket separado
para cada qubit
onde o produto tensorial
entre eles é implícito.
Ou também podemos escrever o
símbolo do produto tensorial explicitamente assim, se preferirmos.
E outra opção é
colocar subscrito nos kets com os nomes dos sistemas
que eles representam assim.
E você pode fazer isso com
o símbolo do produto tensorial ou sem.
Isso às vezes pode ser muito útil para manter as coisas claras.
Esses são apenas estilos diferentes para expressar os mesmos vetores e podemos escolher qualquer um ou o que preferirmos ou
o que fizer mais sentido
para a situação em questão. Quando as coisas ficam mais
complicadas, por exemplo, podemos decidir que um desses
estilos acrescenta clareza
e somos livres para fazer
a escolha que quisermos.
Produtos tensoriais de vetores de estado quântico também são vetores de estado quântico.
Para o caso de dois sistemas, por exemplo, se Phi é um vetor de estado quântico
de um sistema X e Psi é um vetor de estado quântico
de um sistema Y,
então o produto tensorial de Phi e Psi é um vetor de estado quântico de XY.
Chamamos estados como estes de estados produto e semelhante ao que vimos no contexto probabilístico clássico, eles representam independência
entre os sistemas X e Y.
Então, por exemplo, se uma pessoa tem um laboratório
em uma parte do mundo e cria um sistema X e o inicializa no estado quântico Phi
e outra pessoa em
outra parte do mundo de forma independente inicializa um sistema Y no estado quântico Psi,
então se escolhermos tratar XY como formando um único sistema mesmo que sejam duas partes em diferentes partes do mundo,
então o sistema composto XY está
no estado Phi tensorial Psi.
Tudo isso se generaliza para
mais de dois sistemas de forma natural.
Se temos estados quânticos
Psi1 até PsiN de sistemas separados X1 até Xn, então o produto tensorial desses n vetores
representa um estado quântico, que é novamente chamado de estado produto do sistema composto X1 até Xn.
Aqui está um exemplo de um
estado quântico de dois qubits.
Embora possa não
parecer imediatamente. É um exemplo de estado produto porque podemos escrevê-lo
como um produto tensorial como você vê aqui.
Então é um exemplo de
estado produto independentemente de como está escrito, o que é relevante é se
é possível ou não escrevê-lo como um produto tensorial.
Este estado quântico, porém, que é novamente um estado de dois
qubits não é um estado produto.
É semelhante em espírito ao
exemplo que vimos no contexto probabilístico de dois bits aleatórios perfeitamente correlacionados
e o mesmo argumento revela que não pode ser escrito
como um produto tensorial.
Então vamos mover isso aqui e dar uma olhada no argumento com um pouco mais de detalhe.
Vamos imaginar que
pudéssemos escrever esse estado como um produto tensorial de
dois vetores Phi e Psi.
A entrada correspondente
ao estado clássico 0,1 é zero para este vetor, o que podemos ver apenas olhando para ele.
Isso implicaria, porém, se o vetor fosse um produto
tensorial de dois vetores, que a entrada zero de Phi
vezes a entrada um de Psi
seria igual a zero, mas isso significa que ou
a entrada zero de Phi ou a entrada um de Psi é igual a zero
ou ambas poderiam ser iguais a zero, mas isso contradiz o fato de
que esses dois produtos aqui devem ser ambos não nulos.
Eles são iguais a um
sobre raiz quadrada de dois. O argumento é na verdade praticamente
idêntico ao que tínhamos no contexto probabilístico.
Não há nada exclusivamente
quântico nisso.
De qualquer forma, o que encontramos é que o estado original não é um estado produto.
Note que não é importante
que esses dois números aqui sejam um sobre raiz quadrada de dois.
O que importa é que
ambos os valores são não nulos.
Esse estado quântico particular
é um muito interessante. É um exemplo de um
estado entrelaçado de dois qubits.
Falaremos mais sobre
entrelaçamento mais adiante na série.
O entrelaçamento pode ser complicado, particularmente quando estamos
falando sobre estados quânticos na formulação geral
da informação quântica,
mas aqui na descrição simplificada da informação quântica o entrelaçamento é equivalente à ausência de independência.
Então para um vetor de estado quântico,
se não é um estado produto, é um estado entrelaçado
e este estado particular
é comumente visto como
o exemplo arquétipo de um estado quântico entrelaçado.
E de fato, às vezes
pensamos sobre esse estado como representando uma unidade de entrelaçamento, particularmente quando estamos
pensando sobre entrelaçamento
como um recurso que pode ser
usado para fazer coisas interessantes.
O estado quântico do qual
acabamos de falar é um dos quatro chamados estados de Bell, que você pode ver aqui
junto com os nomes
que são comumente usados para esses estados, Phi plus, Phi minus,
Psi plus e Psi minus.
Todos são entrelaçados
e de fato formam uma base para o espaço de todos os
vetores representando estados de dois qubits.
Então esses quatro vetores juntos
são chamados de base de Bell.
É uma coleção muito comum
de estados quânticos, nomeada
em honra de John Bell, que foi um físico que fez
contribuições muito importantes
ao estudo do entrelaçamento nos anos 1960.
Aqui estão alguns exemplos bem conhecidos de estados quânticos de três qubits.
O primeiro é chamado de estado GHZ.
É parecido com o estado Phi
plus que acabamos de ver, mas para três qubits em vez de dois.
E o segundo exemplo é chamado de estado W e parece como você vê aqui, então é uniforme sobre
as três strings binárias
de comprimento três que têm
exatamente um bit definido como um.
Nenhum desses estados é um estado produto e ambos têm propriedades interessantes e aparecem com bastante frequência como exemplos, então vale a pena conhecê-los
e os veremos novamente.
A seguir falaremos sobre
medições de sistemas em estados quânticos.
Seguindo o mesmo raciocínio
que temos seguido até aqui na aula, que é tratar múltiplos sistemas
como se fossem sistemas únicos. Chegamos imediatamente a uma descrição de como medições de
múltiplos sistemas quânticos funcionam
desde que todos os
sistemas sejam medidos.
Ou seja, se temos um
vetor de estado quântico Psi que representa um estado quântico de uma n-upla de sistemas
X1 até Xn e medimos
o sistema composto inteiro, que é equivalente a medir
cada um dos sistemas individuais, então cada possível n-upla
de estados clássicos será o resultado da medição
com probabilidade igual ao
valor absoluto ao quadrado da entrada de Psi que
corresponde a essa n-upla.
Por exemplo, se temos
um par de sistemas XY neste estado quântico aqui, então se medirmos ambos os sistemas,
então obteremos o resultado zero de copas, ou seja, zero para a medição de X e copas para a medição de Y
com probabilidade nove vinte e cinco avos e obteremos o resultado um
espadas com probabilidade dezesseis vinte e cinco avos.
Isso é bastante direto. Estamos essencialmente apenas ignorando o fato de que esses são dois sistemas separados e os tratamos como se
fossem um único sistema,
mas isso levanta a
seguinte questão natural, que já consideramos
no contexto clássico.
Suponha que temos dois sistemas X e Y que estão coletivamente
em algum estado quântico e não medimos ambos, mas
medimos apenas um sistema.
Digamos que medimos o sistema X e não fazemos nada a Y.
Claro, também podemos perguntar o que acontece se medirmos Y e não
X e mais geralmente o que acontece se temos
três ou mais sistemas
e medimos algum subconjunto próprio deles. Mas uma vez que tenhamos uma
resposta para essa pergunta, teremos respostas para
essas perguntas também.
Sabemos que em geral
um vetor de estado quântico do par XY tem a
forma que você vê aqui, supondo como de costume que sigma e gamma
são os conjuntos de estados clássicos
de X e Y respectivamente.
As entradas desse vetor são
denotadas por alfa ab variando sobre todas as possíveis escolhas de a e b,
e podem ser qualquer número complexo que faça deste vetor
um vetor unitário.
Agora já sabemos que se
ambos os sistemas são medidos, então obtemos as probabilidades para os diferentes possíveis resultados
tomando o valor absoluto ao quadrado da entrada correspondente.
E então se apenas X é medido, então a probabilidade de
obter um resultado particular a é dada por esta expressão,
simplesmente somamos sobre todos
os possíveis resultados b, que poderiam ser obtidos
se Y também fosse medido, mesmo que não tenha sido.
A ideia é a mesma que no
contexto probabilístico.
A probabilidade de obter
um resultado particular quando X é medido não pode
possivelmente depender de se Y também foi medido.
Então isso nos diz quais
são as probabilidades para os diferentes possíveis resultados.
Além disso, haverá alguma
mudança no estado de Y como resultado de termos
realizado essa medição em X e obtido um resultado particular.
Então vamos ver como isso funciona.
Semelhante ao que fizemos no
contexto probabilístico, podemos expressar o
vetor de estado quântico Psi como você vê aqui
onde Phi a é esse vetor para cada escolha de um estado clássico a do sistema X,
estamos usando a bilinearidade
do produto tensorial como antes.
Só que agora escolhemos nomear
esses diferentes vetores de Phi a, por conveniência.
Já observamos que a probabilidade de que a medição produza
cada possível resultado a é como você vê aqui,
mas agora podemos ver que essa probabilidade é igual à norma euclidiana
ao quadrado do vetor Phi a,
e agora como resultado da medição de X dando um resultado particular a, temos que o estado quântico
do sistema composto XY
torna-se esse estado que
você vê aqui.
Assim como tínhamos para sistemas únicos, o estado colapsa em essência, mas não colapsa
completamente em geral,
ele apenas colapsa até onde precisa para ser consistente
com a medição de X produzindo o resultado a.
O estado quântico de Y torna-se Phi a normalizado, ou seja, dividimos pela sua norma euclidiana
para que se torne um vetor unitário. Isso é análogo ao que aconteceu no
contexto probabilístico onde em vez de dividir
pela norma euclidiana,
dividíamos pela soma
das entradas de Phi a para obter um vetor de probabilidade.
Mas aqui porque estamos
falando sobre estados quânticos, dividimos pela norma euclidiana
para obter um vetor de estado quântico.
Vamos dar uma olhada em alguns exemplos para ver como isso funciona
para um estado específico.
Aqui está o estado que consideraremos. Estamos supondo que X e Y são qubits e estão neste estado particular Psi.
E suponha que X é medido.
Começamos escrevendo o estado
Psi como você vê aqui, efetivamente isolando os
fatores da base padrão de X
e tensorando-os com o que precisarmos para obter o estado original.
Assim como na descrição geral
de há pouco.
A probabilidade de obter o resultado zero é a norma euclidiana ao quadrado
desse vetor aqui.
A coisa que estamos tensorando ao ket zero na nossa expressão do vetor Psi.
E então a probabilidade é três quartos e condicionado a
obter o resultado zero.
O estado quântico do
par XY torna-se esse onde normalizamos o
vetor tensorado ao ket zero,
e isso é equivalente a
dividir pela raiz quadrada da probabilidade que
acabamos de calcular.
Podemos então simplificar
e é isso que obtemos.
A probabilidade de obter o
resultado de medição um é calculada de forma similar.
Tomamos a norma euclidiana ao quadrado
desse vetor aqui. A coisa que está tensorada ao ket
um na nossa expressão de Psi
e a probabilidade resultante
é um quarto, o que tem que ser, claro, porque nossas probabilidades
devem somar um.
Neste caso, o estado quântico de XY torna-se esse onde novamente normalizamos dividindo pela norma euclidiana
de modo que obtemos esse vetor de estado quântico
como resultado.
O mesmo método é usado
de forma simétrica, se Y é medido em vez de X.
Aqui está o vetor de estado quântico original, e desta vez porque Y
é medido em vez de X,
expressamos o vetor Psi
como você vê aqui, onde desta vez isolamos os
vetores da base padrão de Y
em vez de X, tensorando
com o que precisarmos para obter uma expressão de Psi.
Fazendo o cálculo, que você pode verificar
pausando o vídeo se quiser.
Vemos que a probabilidade
de obter o resultado zero é oito avos desta vez, e aqui está
o vetor de estado quântico
que resulta condicionado
a obter esse resultado.
E a probabilidade de obter o
resultado um é três oitavos, caso em que este é
nosso vetor de estado quântico.
Você pode usar exatamente o mesmo método caso tenha mais de dois sistemas e algum subconjunto próprio
deles seja medido.
E há um exemplo
no conteúdo do livro didático desta aula que você pode
conferir se estiver interessado.
Em resumo, sempre podemos dividir os sistemas em duas coleções separadas, os que são medidos
e os que não são.
E uma vez que fizemos isso, recorremos ao método
que acabei de descrever, e é assim que as medições para múltiplos sistemas quânticos funcionam.
E agora por fim, passamos às operações unitárias
em múltiplos sistemas.
Usando a mesma ideia básica de que múltiplos sistemas podem ser tratados como sistemas compostos únicos.
Concluímos o que você vê
escrito aqui na tela, operações quânticas em sistemas compostos são representadas por matrizes unitárias
assim como temos para sistemas únicos e especificamente as linhas e colunas dessas matrizes unitárias correspondem ao produto cartesiano
dos conjuntos de estados clássicos de qualquer coleção de
sistemas de que estamos falando.
Por exemplo, se temos um sistema X
cujos estados clássicos são um, dois e três e Y é um qubit,
então a matriz que você vê aqui é um exemplo de uma matriz unitária que representa uma
operação no par XY.
Os detalhes de como
ordenamos produtos cartesianos que discutimos antes realmente não importam para
fins desse exemplo, é apenas uma matriz seis por seis
que é unitária.
Não há nada de especial nela, embora seja construída a partir de
algumas matrizes importantes.
O ponto é que você poderia
escolher qualquer matriz unitária seis por seis e ela representaria
uma operação unitária em XY.
Se aplicamos uma coleção de
operações unitárias de forma independente, cada uma em seu próprio sistema, então a ação de todas juntas
no sistema composto é
dada pelo produto tensorial.
E aqui na tela você pode ver uma declaração mais precisa
desse fato.
Se nossas operações unitárias são descritas pelas matrizes unitárias U1 até Un, uma para cada um dos nossos sistemas,
então a ação combinada
no sistema composto é dada pelo produto
tensorial de U1 até Un.
Novamente, semelhante ao que tínhamos no contexto probabilístico, um exemplo importante é que
aplicamos alguma operação unitária
U a um sistema X e não
fazemos nada a algum outro sistema Y.
A operação em XY que obtemos é U tensorial com a matriz identidade.
A matriz identidade
descreve não fazer nada a Y.
Às vezes é útil escrever explicitamente que essa matriz identidade
corresponde ao sistema Y, apenas para tornar as fórmulas mais claras.
E uma opção é
dar à matriz identidade um subscrito assim que indica o sistema no qual ela atua.
Quando está claro o suficiente, porém, normalmente não nos
incomodamos com um subscrito, mas quando as coisas ficam mais complicadas, pode ser muito útil.
E também podemos considerar
o caso simétrico onde alguma operação unitária
V é aplicada a Y e nada é feito a X,
e desta vez a operação unitária resultante em XY é representada por esse
produto tensorial aqui.
E novamente, podemos colocar um subscrito na
matriz identidade se ajudar.
Aqui estão alguns exemplos específicos.
Se X e Y são qubits e
realizamos uma operação Hadamard em X e não fazemos nada a Y, obtemos a matriz que você vê aqui.
Se por outro lado, realizamos a operação Hadamard em Y e não fazemos nada a X, a ordenação do produto tensorial é invertida.
E assim obtemos a matriz
que você vê aqui.
Nem toda operação unitária
em um sistema composto pode ser expressa como um produto tensorial.
Se temos um produto tensorial,
então temos independência.
E há alguns exemplos bastante
fundamentais de operações que certamente
não atuam de forma independente em múltiplos sistemas.
Por exemplo, se X e Y têm
o mesmo conjunto de estados clássicos, que pode ser qualquer
conjunto de estados clássicos sigma,
então podemos pensar sobre a
operação swap no par XY.
Essa operação não muda a ordenação dos dois sistemas, ainda temos X à
esquerda e Y à direita, mas representa a troca
do conteúdo
dos dois sistemas. Aqui você pode ver isso expresso
na forma de uma equação onde temos um produto
tensorial de dois estados quânticos.
Outra forma de escrever é como
uma matriz como vemos aqui.
A forma de pensar sobre
essa descrição é que ela diz o que acontece para vetores da base padrão.
E uma vez que sabemos o que acontece
para vetores da base padrão, sabemos o que acontece para
estados quânticos arbitrários por linearidade,
o que de fato também vale para
essa expressão aqui.
Então essa operação particular aqui é também uma operação determinística além de uma operação unitária.
Se X e Y são qubits, por exemplo, obtemos esta representação matricial
aqui.
Aqui está uma conexão interessante
entre a operação swap e os quatro estados de Bell, que são mostrados aqui
por conveniência.
A operação swap deixa os
primeiros três deles inalterados, mas coloca um sinal de menos na
frente do estado Psi minus,
então há algo
especial nesse.
Você pode verificar essas equações diretamente olhando para esses vetores e considerando o que acontece
para os estados da base padrão
trocar os dois estados clássicos para os primeiros três estados de Bell
não faz nada, obtemos o mesmo estado com que começamos.
No quarto caso, porém, o sinal de menos efetivamente
passa de um termo para o outro quando realizamos o swap dos estados clássicos,
e isso é equivalente a multiplicar o vetor por menos um.
Então realizar a operação swap de alguma forma expele um sinal de menos
desse quarto estado de Bell.
Teremos mais a dizer sobre
essas equações mais adiante, mas agora vamos passar para
outro tipo de operação, que é uma operação controlada.
Vamos supor que X é um qubit e Y é qualquer sistema que você queira.
Se U é uma operação unitária em Y, então uma operação U controlado em XY é a operação expressa aqui.
Primeiro, usando a notação de Dirac e depois usando o que se
chama de matriz em blocos, você simplesmente imagina preenchendo essa matriz maior
com as menores onde esses zeros realmente representam matrizes
preenchidas com zeros.
Então cada um desses quatro blocos representa uma matriz com um número
de linhas e colunas que concorda com o número
de estados clássicos de Y.
A ideia de uma operação controlada, que já encontramos
no contexto clássico quando discutimos uma
operação NOT controlado,
é que se X está definido como zero,
então nada acontece a Y.
Mas se X está definido como um,
então U é aplicado a Y.
Então X é chamado de qubit de controle, e Y é chamado de sistema alvo, que em geral
não precisa ser um qubit.
Para um exemplo específico,
que acabei de mencionar, temos uma operação NOT controlado.
Se o primeiro qubit está definido
como zero, nada acontece. E se o primeiro qubit está definido como um, então uma operação NOT ou equivalentemente,
uma operação sigma X é
aplicada ao segundo qubit.
E aqui está sua representação matricial.
Estamos falando sobre dois qubits aqui, então poderíamos igualmente bem
decidir que o segundo qubit é o controle e o
primeiro é o alvo.
Para descrever essa operação, basta trocar a ordenação
no produto tensorial, e o resultado é a matriz
que você vê aqui.
Se em vez de uma operação NOT controlado, consideramos uma sigma
Z controlado ou operação Z controlado.
Obtemos esta representação
matricial aqui. E para esta, realmente não importa
qual é o controle e qual é o alvo.
Obtemos o mesmo resultado de qualquer forma.
Podemos ir mais longe e podemos considerar uma operação swap controlado.
E aqui estamos
falando de trocar dois qubits, então terminamos com três qubits quando incluímos o qubit de controle.
A representação matricial
é esta aqui.
É uma operação bastante especial e é conhecida como operação Fredkin, ou mais comumente gate Fredkin.
Quando pensamos nisso
como um gate em um circuit, discutiremos circuits na próxima aula.
O último exemplo é uma operação NOT controlado controlado, que novamente é uma
operação em três qubits.
E aqui está sua representação matricial. Esta operação é muito mais
conhecida como operação Toffoli ou gate Toffoli.
Discutiremos mais
e veremos por que tanto ela quanto a operação Fredkin são operações muito importantes
em uma aula posterior.
E esse é o fim da segunda aula. Nesta aula, discutimos como a informação quântica funciona para múltiplos sistemas.
Espero que te junte a mim para
a terceira aula em breve, que é sobre circuits quânticos,
protocolos e jogos.
Até lá!